the book of boba fett the new line of
star wars content is by far the most
inconsistent in terms of quality this
show is divided into three parts which
are the upbringing of boba fett's
criminal empire his origin after falling
into the sarlacc pit and her prologue
for the mandalorian season 3. although i
really enjoyed the mandalorian story
development it feels misplaced because
it's taking the spotlight away from boba
fett within his own story when looking
at the run times we only get 66 minutes
of development for boba fett where he
builds his empire in the present
and this isn't including the finale
which is mostly just pure action and
also includes the mandalorian
development so to compare this to how
much screen time we get for the
mandalorian the run time for that is 60
minutes the fact that we don't really
get a solid story for boba fett is so
underwhelming and the story we do get
feels rushed and is riddled with flaws
some rushed aspects include the whole
spice conflict since we never see the
ramifications as to why the spice trade
is ruining the planet besides the pikes
killing some tuscans moss espan the
whole criminal underworld feels very
small and superficial the characters
within the world never break out of
their one-dimensional archetypes and
barely get any screen time like we have
the generic club owner replaceable
random mafia aliens and some forgettable
villains and allies
really the only interesting new
character is a black wookie cursanten
given that he actually has a tangible
backstory and has a cool design unlike
the generic cyberpunk people then the
plot as well is expedited at times an
example being that boba fett wants to
learn to ride a ring core and that it
takes a lot of time to forge a bond with
one to boba fett suddenly riding in at a
rancor during the finale to save the day
without any buildup of him forging that
bond like sure it can happen off screen
but by doing so they are skipping over
that part of the story and the payoff
doesn't feel as earned another example
is the huts giving up so quickly to get
rid of boba fetts they come into the
story since they still believe that
tattooing belongs to them and are
willing to kill boba fett to achieve
that goal and in order to get closer to
that goal they send corsantin to take
out boba which that whole scene is a
complete mess because how did this huge
wookie sneakily infiltrate this palace
does bubba have literally no guards on
watch can anyone stumble in he doesn't
come across as very threatening when his
only muscle some pigs and angry robo
teams besides fenic obviously but
getting back to the assassination
attempt it falls into the action trope
of the antagonist being able to kill the
hero but instead throws them around
because they have plot armor and aren't
allowed to die
once corsantin or chrysanthen i don't
really care at this point is inevitably
defeated the huts are immediately like
oh okay never mind we're just going to
leave now after trying to kill you sorry
we don't want a war with you or the
mayor
like what did you expect were you going
to get control back that easily this
whole conflict evaporates instantly and
makes this story feel even more rushed
getting into some more writing flaws and
weird story directions let's talk about
boba fett the direction that writers
take him is very pg when this is a story
about a criminal underworld in almost
every scene with boba fett he comes
across as a pushover like he almost got
killed by assassins twice and each time
he lets them go and he never comes
across as hostile
even when people are talking to him and
are being disrespectful he doesn't clash
back or show that he should be respected
then another weird story direction slash
edition is the cyberpunk gang i don't
know who the hell at lucasfilm thought
this was a good idea to have these
stupid vespas in the star wars universe
they look absolutely absurd and they
give off the image of power rangers the
whole chase scene with the cyber kids
scooting after the mayor's spoke person
is honestly one of the worst star wars
scenes i've seen in a while it's
hilarious to me that robert rodriguez
probably thinks this is some badass
chase scene when it comes across as
comical then for one more odd story
direction choice we have the writers
bringing back cad bane just to kill him
an episode later now personally i
believe that he isn't permanently dead
and may come back given that they've
been bringing back characters left and
right by giving the excuse of cybernetic
enhancements to save their lives but if
he stays dead then that's an extremely
weird writing choice
one last thing about the writing is that
there are a lot of small writing
mistakes throughout most of the episodes
i'll run through some quickly boba fett
gets jumped by the nightwind assassins
and instead of stabbing him in a spot
without armor they only shock him just
seems like a very convoluted way to kill
someone and shows that boba's plot armor
again as a side note the editing in the
scene is atrocious and you can even see
boba fett fall down twice
for the rooftop chase
fennec dives off the rooftop when
getting attacked and somehow teleports
in front of the assassins running in an
opposite direction dozens of tuscans get
killed but it doesn't seem like it ever
matters because their village is always
populated boba fett being able to
communicate specific instructions and
plans to the tuscans via hand gestures
is absurd the whole cyber kitty chase
scene was irrelevant given that boba
fett has a jet pack the writers change
the rancor into a misunderstood puppy
bubba fit almost kills himself by
putting a ship into the sarlacc pit
without making sure it was dead first
for a contrived tension-inducing moment
during the finale the gang makes a plan
to station people all over mossaspa to
make sure that they don't get surprised
by the pikes but they somehow waltz in
without anyone noticing cad benches up
at the beginning of the finale and then
disappears to then conveniently reappear
again at the end to fight boba fett and
all the action in the finale really
showcases plot armor since the enemy is
deathly allergic to hitting their
targets
even the big battle droids are clearly
missing this massive group of people
running away
i don't think they hit anyone besides
the rancor at point-blank range
so overall to me the story arc of boba
fett overcoming the pike syndicate was
poorly done especially since the pikes
don't become the main antagonist until
the end of episode 3. then for the
origin story it was extremely hit or
miss on one hand i like the arc of bubba
finding a family in the tuscans and
learning that you're stronger as a pact
and then on the other hand there were
long laborious scenes that made his arc
a slog to get through and made it to
where i wish we were back in the present
because we already know boba's endpoint
and there's not many things in between
that time that are overly intriguing
also tuscans only yell in screech so
it's hard to form any attachment to them
for fenix shand i was excited to see the
relationship build up between her and
boba fett but it felt underwhelming
given that one of her big reasons she's
actually working with him is because
she's getting a cut of the success i was
hoping for a more personal and deep
relationship between them but i guess
that's kind of hard when both boba and
fanuc are pretty bland in terms of
character traits for runtime comparison
all of this backstory takes up 92
minutes in the first four episodes which
is significantly more screen time than
what we get in the present so the fact
that we primarily get an origin story
when the show is advertised as boba fett
controlling a criminal underworld is
undeniably disappointing
then for the third surprising piece of
the show we have the mandalorian season
3 and pretty much everything about it is
excellent the writing direction of the
story production design and action
choreography
i love that din jarn was essentially a
noob with the dark saber and ended up
injuring himself with it it doesn't
paint him as a mary sue who instantly
knows how to use a lightsaber after
picking it up like ray or finn he
actually has to learn how to use it
which allows for character growth for
baby yoda i was perfectly satisfied with
how his story ended in season 2 of the
mandalorian where was a heartfelt
goodbye to a traveling companion that
blossomed into a father and son
relationship and by saying goodbye
denjarin was doing what was best for
grogu to me that was a magnificent
ending and by bringing him back i hope
it's not just because they caved into
the baby yoda hype sensation and
actually have a solid future for grogu
and i'm not saying that i disliked his
return i thoroughly enjoyed his scenes
where he trained with luke and meeting
up with din jarn didn't feel contrived
in any way since grogey made that
decision naturally but getting back to
the book of boba fett it's weird how
dave filoni and john favreau chose not
to include all of that into season three
of the mandalorian it kind of comes
across as making the book of boba fett a
required viewing to continue the
mandalorian storyline if you initially
weren't interested in boba fett so yeah
those are the drastic lows and highs of
the show and let me know in the comments
what you thought and thanks for watching
[Music]